honestly can I remember the last time
Tim burns made a movie without a
pale-faced Johnny Depp until today
Frankenweenie is a new stop motion
animated film by Tim Burton it's
actually really special for him because
it was one of the first shorts he ever
made it's all in black and white it's
very stylish it's about this little kid
he just he loves his dog so much and
when his dog dies he decides to try to
recreate him in this very Frankenstein
esque wave he brings his dog back to
life with the scientific experiment
which then causes all these other
problems with other animals which causes
other problems with the people in the
county that he lives in and it causes
this huge adventure where this kid and
this dog have to get out of all these
problems they've now caused simply
because they just want to be together
Frankenweenie is a movie that I was kind
of excited for simply because I love
stop-motion animation I've always really
enjoyed it ParaNorman was great I loved
Coraline and although there are some
great timber and movies I've loved
there's a lot of times where I just kind
of get sick of the whole gothic thing
and you know do something a little
different and you know what even though
there's definitely staple Tim Burton
things in this movie like you know the
dark creepy style
the children's movie that's not really
for children and the long suburban
streets where there's some sort of
mountain range in the background or
something you know where everyone's just
on this perfect little suburbia
neighborhood made for Tim Burton land
although it has a lot of those Tim
Burton cliches in it I really enjoyed
Frankenweenie and that's because of the
heart that was in this film and the
adventure and the whimsical nature of
the movie and has a really good feel to
it and it's different it has a lot of
strange quirks and I don't just mean
because it's Tim Burton and his movies
are always a little off-kilter it had
that same thing a ParaNorman had where
characters kind of mumble things and
they're quiet and they're not like
really loud and everything and not
everything is really over exaggerated
like it isn't a lot of animation it's
very toned down it's kind of quiet and
it's a little more adult it's not really
for young kids this movie isn't a little
girl that was sitting next to me and my
friend was crying through most of the
movie and eventually the mom had to take
her out because she was too young
I however liked it because of that I
like when you go to a film that's like a
family film but it ends up having stuff
for adults in there too and it's kind of
creepy and I like that off scale that
some of Tim Burton's movies have Danny
Elfman score is also really good and it
was really fun I want to pick it up
for sure it wasn't his typical like oh
you know he's that that's my that's my
danny elfman impression you know how all
of his scores for timbre noise had like
this really loud choir in the background
this one was different I liked it the
heart of the movie is a relationship
between the boy and the dog and it
hinges on how much you feel for that
relationship on whether or not you will
love like or just not like this movie
that relationship is the heart of this
movie and I thought it was sweet it
wasn't overdone it wasn't too sappy it
wasn't all cutesy I had a dog when I was
a kid and I loved that dog and I
understand that and so I was so attached
to that dog and so I kind of understand
this movie probably more than someone
who's never had a dog would some of the
problems I had with the movie are that
it does have like some big ideas it
likes to preach a little bit about
science and everything and I liked
actually some of those situations where
it caused you know discussions they were
actually kind of adult and that kids
aren't going to understand and I really
like those scenes it was just that they
didn't always mesh with the more
whimsical adventurous side of the film
and then there was like this side of it
was actually seeing something and
although both of those sides were
definitely entertaining at times it felt
a little off from the tone scale of
things but know that it's not your
typical animation that's why I liked it
and it's not flat-out hilarious it's
actually kind of creepy and towards the
end the actual finale of the film I was
actually really getting into it it was
kind of riveting actually and a lot of
fun so I enjoyed Frankenweenie I'm gonna
give it a B it's not my favorite
animation of the year so far but I did
really enjoy it I'd say ParaNorman still
takes the cake for favorite animation
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you liked this review then you
can click right here and get stuck mini
iced
Oh